a few days ago i posted a clip of the
comedian bill burr doing a bit about
abortion that was
pretty conservative
if you would have to say it was broadly
on the right or was making points that
were on the right so i thought it was
great it was really funny i thought this
is good if this is where the
counterculture is this is where the pop
culture is moving good news for
conservatives my producers tell me there
is another comedian younger comedian
andrew schultz who had a comedy bit go
viral over the past few weeks that
similarly is not exactly leftist so i
haven't seen it yet they're going to
play it for me let's take a look loki
biden is more entertaining than trump
[Music]
the guy is [ __ ] unbelievable
but they don't let him out the basement
that's the thing
[Music]
you think he lives in the white house
how'd he get lost in the lawn did you
see that
remember when they let him out the
basement they took the leash off and he
walked into a bush in his own house
he walked straight into a bush
disappeared like a homer simpson meme
just
just completely disappeared you do that
in your home there's no [ __ ] way you
do that in your home bro he fell up the
stairs you don't remember that
375 years old hit some stairs roll to
the [ __ ] top of them to find physics
that's how bad he wants to go to heaven
he's like because this is their way any
way i could get to heaven give me the
[ __ ] out of here
there was a month where every child
within two feet of him he bear hug and
sniff their head you don't remember that
one whole month every single kid just
they started giving them jewish kids so
there'd be a little protection he was
yanking off yarmulkes
and just sniffing dandruff off their
skulls
even
bruh
son hunter was like you saw that's
dandruff the whole family
the whole family's interesting
that bit's really interesting because
you know bill burr who's been in the
business obviously much longer he's been
it forever
bill burr's kind of right-wing comedy
was it wasn't so overt he started off
with that whole
listen i think abortion's totally cool i
totally support a woman's right to
choose but it is killing a baby and then
as the bit went on you realized more and
more he was he was making points that
totally undercut abortion you walk in
with a baby you come out without one
what happened to the baby but you didn't
exactly know necessarily at the
beginning andrew schultz he's just
coming right out the gate he's like
biden is a senile old coot he's a
daughter and he's just
completely a joke and
to me i mean i obviously haven't seen
the whole special to me though what that
says about the culture is all right
no holds barred all bets are off
everyone knows biden's a joke even
though he tested negative uh not that
much changes for biden he still works
from home avoids crowds and takes 20
pills a day
it's totally safe to make jokes about
how biden is a joke that audience that
theater is completely sold out and
that's a huge theater
this is really good i got to go watch
the rest of this special this is making
me feel much much better about november
2022
[Music]
[Music]